hello and welcome to this video in
English opening again do I get the same
line you get it off really you
oh sorry I'm more aware now that age
five is a good move
you
yeah what is doing father he's not
some calcining prematurely
and I know that this looks odd yeah the
snide if I have sir but I've looked at
this in fact and I think black is in
reasonable shape even though it does
look odd I admit that I'm happy um I'm
willing happy as wrong spelling I'm
willing to admit that it looks odd
speaking of what is that why why is such
a move that makes any sense
a queen wants to just
Bishop to b6 and then retreat okay
yeah there's Bishop III sometimes but I
can still currently
you
[Music]
reply with night c4 I wanted to sing see
does he want to clean a day for here
maybe
anyway
you
you
first let's get rid of this Bishop okay
it makes sense though the bishop Wow
really that that cannot be right
I just refuse to believe it if I take it
it must be bad
okay
[Music]
you okay I have a pretty whacky
knowledge on frm all right but
everything else looks good
in fact mmm I cannot immediately
No
I don't know if pseudo g5 is a bit of a
bitter will make him move I mean I just
want to see what he's doing next
Oh
you
don't think that helps much
just one too windy five very simple
and also I want to introduce this idea
to play b6 97 94 and that should be
quite helpful get this back into the
game
you
you
he's going right into 95 that's funny
90 to 95 even traps his own queen kukris
our queen ephors are very cooperative
move
[Music]
you
you
you
you
very likely just winning all the pawns D
5 D 3 a2
in the more
okay take it take then take the first
one it was hanging
you three is hanging
this one
you
you
you
yeah I don't know yes just so many good
good moves
you
you
you
I also could have tried to play form the
f3 pawn
taketake g-form that's a bit of a fancy
play
it's pretty strong I think
all of a sudden switching sites
threatening night f4 is going to be very
powerful mean where is he going with the
king
can have too many
I just want to get Becker animated
that's why I took a moment
napping back remedies only difficult to
envision here
you
okay I don't see a maid then just do
this
hmm there was a bit of art I think at
the beginning it looked kind of come
from normal but yeah so 97 before
castles be fine
I've looked at this kind of position
once and I was surprised that this is
kind of okay it looks odd but it's kind
of okay you have d5 as black
sometimes c5 or c6 it's it's not like
back it's better but it's it's a player
position these three I should be six
Queen a4
Bishop c5 is stronger okay well ever
let's set some look I think this should
be kind of okay castles are age three
and now there are some some weird moves
even I don't believe it
why would you what is stops alright yeah
I'm just getting a more active Bishop
okay um f-full by white
we're for age three yeah that is
definitely better than this you just
immediately giving me an advantage
the points are all week and some we're
just extremely awkward and Jim here was
a bit of a lazy move I guess but it did
it really paid off queenie for us
now a very very awful just win all the
pawns so I already just don't like efore
and then with 95 he was giving me a huge
advantage probably as the engines like
what does the tempest should did - we
have something like that here I think
rather white should be better I mean as
mentioned this is a playable position
for Blackie but it's not like in tests
like
see six maybe
okay you can be advantageous to take
with Queen iam
hmm the engine evaluates us as roughly
equal it's just that the sisters dead up
eform you don't have a foothold in the
center and f5 is something that
immediately activates my position so you
should definitely avoid that with white
okay thanks so much for watching